- I don't like mindless
content. I've never liked it.
I like to think about what I'm watching,
what I'm taking in, what I'm listening to.
Yeah, humor's always been an
important part of my life.
Like, since, like, middle school.
- Hello, Believe Nation, it's Evan.
My one word is believe
and I believe in people
more than they believe in themselves.
And my sincere hope is
that if you see in yourself
what I see you, you'll be
able to change the planet.
So to help you on your journey,
today, we're going to learn
from stand-up comedian and
actor, Jerrod Carmichael.
It's a good last name.
And my take on his top
10 rules for success.
Rule number one is my
personal favorite, and
I'd love to know which one
you guys like the best.
Also, as you're watching, if
you hear something that really
resonates with you, please
leave it down in the
comments below and put
quotes around it so other
people can be inspired by it as well.
And if you leave it within
the first couple hours
of this video going live,
you have a chance to win one
of two daily prizes.
(swoosh)
(upbeat music)
- I don't like mindless
content. I've never liked it.
I like to think about what I'm watching,
what I'm taking in, what I'm listening to.
So, even music, I can't
listen to music that
doesn't challenge me in
anyway and I never could.
It's just kind of who I am as a person.
It was, I guess, embedded
in my DNA to just, really
want to feel something,
figure something out.
And not just tell jokes for
the sake of telling jokes.
I like to say things that,
at least, can be meaningful.
And ...
People ...
I know that I'm doing my
job when I see someone react
other than just a laugh,
actually give me a reaction.
And it's not always just
turning as much as it's just
like, "Oh no" like,
people shaking their head.
Comedy, a lot of times, has
become this court jester type
thing where everyone just goes
says the craziest, brashest,
most outlandish absurd silly
thing and it means nothing.
And I don't want to say things
that don't mean anything.
- So you like sort of
putting the audience in a
scenario where they could turn on you.
And then it's a
- Yeah.
- bit more work for you as the artist
to kind of make sure that they don't.
- Yeah. Yeah. It's more
work, it's more exciting,
and it' more fulfilling.
- When did you notice that I can do this
and I can turn a phrase
or make people laugh at
something that they didn't see before?
- 8th grade was really big.
- Oh yeah?
- Yeah, it was an important time for me.
Just having this teacher
that encouraged me
to read a lot independently.
And to question everything,
gather information.
I remember one time, he started
doing these class debates
and there was this article.
I don't remember exactly what
was in the article but it was
about a man that committed a crime
but he had a somewhat
righteous cause for doing it.
I remember those details
- Okay.
- But, he was dividing up the class and
who agreed with this guy
and thought that he was
justified in doing it and who disagreed.
I remember he said "who
thinks he wasn't justified?"
And the entire class except
me raised their hand.
- Really?
- And then you know, like,
"well, who agrees with the guy?"
And I raised my hand and then
we argued for like 25 minutes.
I remember it being the
most fun time I'd ever
had in class, ever had in school.
It meant the most to
me and I just remember
holding my own against 20 other students.
- That's sounds strangely
akin to stand up because
it's one guy with the whole sort of
audience that you have
to sort of win over.
- Yeah, exactly and I
think that one experience,
that single experience, it formed
so much of my life for humor.
More than any individual
experience I can think of.
- It must have also been
notable that you were
the only person that took
an opposing view point.
- Yeah, and it was natural.
And that's kind of a rule
for stand-up for me too
is that never be
contrarian for the sake of.
- Right.
- Always have a truthful
intention behind what you say.
Because that's what
people will connect with.
That's what will give license
to people's attention.
People will actually give you
their time if they know that
it's coming from an honest
place and that it's really
a thought or emotion that
you want to work out.
I think that people respond to that.
- When did you know that this
is what your calling was?
- When I was depressed
working at a shoe store.
I was like, you know, I got
to do something else. (laughs)
- [Dan] Were you a funny salesman?
- Yeah. Humor's always been
an important part of my life.
Since, like, middle school.
- [Dan] But you were selling tennis shoes?
- Selling tennis shoes. But
you use it for anything.
You use it for whatever you're working on.
- [Dan Patrick] You
meet women in that way?
- Yeah. That was my way in.
- [Dan] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- [Dan] Through their feet?
- Yeah, through their feet. (laughs)
I never really met
girls at the shoe store.
You meet 'em at, a, ...
- [Dan] Oh, okay.
everywhere else but humor
was the most important thing.
- You talk about gentrification and
how it's affecting folks.
It's not that it's funny,
it's that it's real
that makes us laugh.
- Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
- And that's the kind of
smart, intelligent comedy
that I feel like you guys
are writing on this show
that you're touching on real
ass issues while laughing
because we're laughing at ourselves.
- People connect with
truth more than anything.
- Yeah.
- Especially, I mean,
we live in a time where
we were just talking about it
there's so many reality shows
and so many things to
where people see reality
and they live in it in
their entertainment so much
that if you turn on a sitcom
and people are just saying
these crazy things that
you know isn't real life
then you have nothing to truly respond to.
- Yo, that's why I can't
watch a lot of the old sitcoms
unless I'm just trying
to escape and go dumb.
- Yeah.
- [Female] Ha.
- Right?
- [Female] Wow.
- I don't want people ...
With anything, I never want
people to turn their minds off.
- It's like all of the art that I love,
my favorite artists, my
favorite rappers, my favorites
make me think and make
me question things and
I have to listen again
and I have to watch again.
- [Sway] Mm-hmm.
- And so, I just want
to contribute to that.
- [Sway] Mm-hmm.
- With the show and with
stand-up or anything.
- Did exploring apathy or
at least sort of your fear
of not feeling enough or the
feelings about not feeling
in this special shot just a
few days after the election
did it feel kind of dangerous or
like you were walking a thin line?
Cause I will say when I was watching it,
there was something about
like that was one of the most
dangerous things that I felt I had seen a
comedian do in a long time.
- (laughs) yeah.
- And it wouldn't have been that dangerous
- Yeah.
- A year ago. But there
was something about you
walking that rope and trying
to make this approachable
for people and make them relate to you and
understand you and not turn on you.
- Yeah. Which is the fun part of it.
- Yeah.
- That's where it's fun.
You know, I mean, that's
where comedy is it's most fun.
And I think can be at it's best where it's
someone exploring an unpopular
thought or emotion on stage
and I like to treat audience
members like the adults that
they are and we can have a
discussion and you can completely
disagree with me you can feel
the opposite of how I feel
and still listen and still
understand and still ...
My job is to articulate my
point and I just try and
articulate my point and
hopefully you laugh at the end
or at least feel something.
- Do you think that there's a line that
people should or shouldn't cross?
Or do you think that that
line itself is it just like
well, is it funny and do you
have an original thought?
And if you don't then there's
probably a line for you.
- You should have a intention.
You know. The line is
where your intention is.
If your intention is
to just say some crazy
into a microphone, then maybe you
shouldn't have a microphone.
Like I'm just going to say the
most absurd thing in the world
and you're going to get mad
and whatev ... like, no.
But if you're intention
is to explore a thought,
then there is no line.
- How did you develop your stand-up act?
- Just kind of doing it. I just jumped in.
I didn't ... I'm from North Carolina
but I started in L.A. cause I
just wanted, I'm competitive.
- [Dan] Did you go to the comedy store?
- I'm competitive in that sense.
- [Dan] Oh, you are?
- That's where the heart
of an athlete (laughs)
is where you're just wanting to
- [Dan] So you're the Jordan of comedy
is what you're saying?
- God bless you.
- [Dan] Yes.
(laughs)
- NBC is in a place of
redevelopment which is kind of why I
was attracted to NBC in the first place.
I only pitched to NBC cause I was only
going to sell it to NBC.
- Really?
- Because I was making a show for NBC.
- Wow
- And you know and partly-
- Usually you pitch to 10 people.
- Yeah, yeah and I did you know
I did a deal with Universal
because, yeah, they can
pitch to other places but
I knew NBC would be first
and that's the only place
I was going to do the show. That was it.
- I understand the show
was a realization of
a life long dream of yours?
- I always wanted a show on NBC.
That was kind of of a, yeah.
- Starting at what age?
- I think I was like, 11 or 12.
I used to tell my brother
and my family I wanted a show
on NBC because a lot of my
favorite shows were on there.
Everything from, I watched
television with my parents
so I watched Cheers and The
Cosby Show and you watch,
you know A Different World
and you watch Seinfeld
and we watched all these
things and I was like,
well I want to be on that.
Fresh prince is on that, you know.
And that was kind of the goal.
I wanted Thursday nights
at eight but, you know,
Wednesdays at nine is fine. You know.
You can't have it all, Larry.
- When you're making a decision
to discuss a specific issue,
social or political or whatever
it may be, what's going on?
Is it, are you building
a story around that issue
or does the issue happen
authentically through
the story you wanted
to tell to begin with?
- A lot of times it's based on
discussions, arguments,
topics, that I talk about with my friends,
that I talk about with my family.
Then we just explore it honestly.
And ask questions and explore
curiosity and that's it.
Never the illusion of edge of, you know,
cause if you're going to
pick these topics it's like,
well I like speaking to
adults and I have adult
conversations, like the best
version that I know how to have
given the format.
And again just being as real
as possible like not ...
There isn't a message.
There's no message.
I'm not trying to get, I'm
not trying to convince you
one way or another.
I'm just trying to have an
honest conversation and be funny.
(laughs) you know, it's
just that that's really it.
Because I don't want to
step into a pulpit you know,
a lot of art is starting
to reflect that and
it's more aspirational than real
and I don't want to be that.
I don't have a cause that I'm championing.
I don't have a, and we're going to do, no,
I just want a funny show
that's not lying to you.
- [Dan] Where do you get your thoughts,
inspiration when you do stand-up?
- Uh ...
- Like, how do you mine
that and not kind of
cheat on The Carmichael Show?
- They all kind of come together
cause like a lot of times
if you look in my stand-up
a lot of times you'll hear a
lot of those things in the show.
Like it just kind of bleeds
into, cause it's all perspective
so as long as I feel
strongly about something,
I can use it for whatever I'm working on.
With stand-up, a lot of
times, it's the thought that
I'm running from the most.
Like the thing that I'm
a little nervous about,
a little hesitant about and
those are the things that
that excite me and are usually the most
fulfilling things to do on stage.
- [Dan] What makes you nervous?
- Nothing really. It's not
that it makes me nervous
as much as that I know that
it's a tightrope. You know?
Like just to get this thought out it's
going to kind of be of difficult. (laughs)
you know those are the things
that it gets me excited.
I'm never really nervous but it's like the
things that are going
to be hard to repeat is.
I'm trying to make it hard for you to
come back here and repeat later.
- Bill Cosby.
(laughter)
- Well, you all are already very excited.
- I want to start by saying
that I met Bill Cosby
and he was very nice to me.
(laughter)
- To me.
Obviously I can't speak for about 55 women
who may have had a less
than enjoyable experience
(laughter)
- With the Cos.
- But he was very nice to me.
(laughter)
- I went to his house.
I did.
We had tea.
(laughter)
I don't remember much after the tea.
(loud laughter)
- I'm kidding, obviously,
I was not drugged and raped by Bill Cosby.
But we, I don't know, I emailed him.
I emailed him. I wanted to reach out
cause you guys are being so mean to him.
(laughter)
- Didn't write anything
in the body of the email.
(laughter)
- I only wrote in the subject line.
I did. You want to know
what I wrote? Uh-huh.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- I wrote "Hey, my nigga, you good?"
That's what I wrote to Bill Cosby.
(loud laughter)
- I don't know if he's going to respond.
I don't know if he checks his email.
(laughter)
- If he does, he'll ...
- Can we talk about how
difficult it is for me?
This whole Bill Cosby thing.
A lot of you may not relate.
Maybe he wasn't your favorite comic.
Maybe you don't do comedy.
But for me he was a, you know,
an important person in my life. You know?
An inspiration if you will
and it's hard. You know.
It's hard. I'm, you know
it's not that I'm, I'm not
making any excuses at all. You know.
Like would I let him give
my mom headache medication?
Of course not.
(laughter)
- But, it's hard watching
your hero fall from grace.
It's hard. Really is.
I mean for me, this whole
Bill Cosby thing is like
watching Superman rescue a
boy from a burning building
and then immediately molest that boy.
(laughter)
- You know, leaving me to emotionally
weigh the good with the bad.
(laughter)
- I want to see the good in him.
I want to see the good
in everybody. You know.
I try and take what I call
the best friend perspective.
You know. Where even if someone
did something evil or wrong,
I try and see the good in em. You know.
Like a best friend.
(laughter)
- Like even at Hitler's funeral.
- There was still some dude
who had to get up there and speak.
(laughter)
- And it was hard for him.
(laugher)
- Society just hating Hitler.
He knows that Hitler was his best friend
and he tried to find nice things to say.
(laughter)
- Stand up there with his
speech over the coffin.
Angry reporters.
Look,
what can you say about the guy, you know.
(laughter)
- I know a lot of you hated him. I get it.
- But you don't understand, like
he helped pay for my
daughter's braces man.
He was a good dude.
(laughter)
- He was a good dude. Okay.
I know the whole Holocaust thing but
he used to make these quesadillas, man.
(loud laughter)
- And trust me, you
haven't had a quesadilla
till you had a Hitler quesadilla.
(laughter)
- It was something (mumbles)
(swoosh)
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Malik Jordan asked me to.
If there's someone
you'd like me to profile
in a future Top 10, please
check out the link down in
the description below and
you can cast your vote
on who we should do next.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Bhekisisa.
Thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
"Your One Word" and posting
to Twitter about it as well.
I really really really
appreciate the support
and I'm so glad that you enjoyed the read.
Thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love. I'll see you soon.
(swoosh)
- Surround yourself
with like-minded people.
All my friends ...
The thing that I feel luckiest with
is like the group of
people that I'm around.
I really have excellent friends
who, like care about like
making things and creating
and like don't get caught up in
trivial things that won't matter tomorrow.
Like we don't get caught up in things
that don't matter tomorrow.
Don't get me wrong, we
like new experiences and
we like having fun but we like work ...
I was at my office with friends until
six this morning.
Five or six this morning
just like, just ... and it
(crosstalk)
- [Interviewer] In this context.
- [Jerrod] Yeah, on Saturday night.
My entire Saturday, I don't
go out (snorts) really,
like, you know, do too much.
Like you know every now and
then but for the most part,
like just work and my
friends think like that.
- Do you find it difficult
to tell some of these stories
that you want to tell in the
allotted time you're given?
- I mean there's always like a,
I'm not sure which mic I'm
using here. Boom. There we go.
There's always a thing or
two that falls out, you know
that you're excited about,
that you, ah you really wish
this point or joke or
whatever could make it in but.
The, what, 21, 50, whatever
the amount that we get is
- [Female] 21.
- been okay.
- [Female] 21, 45.
- 21, 45, yeah, somewhere around there.
- [Female] Something small.
- Something small.
But we, I'm happy with it
It's a fun obstacle to
try and write around that.
Try and capture everything you want to say
in that amount of time.